-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. Thank you.
You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
Fun show tonight.
Cameron Diaz
on the show tonight.
That's our pal.
-Cammy D.
-Let's get to some news, guys.
Well, it finally happened.
After more than three weeks
without a speaker,
Republicans got on the same page
and elected Mike Johnson
as the new Speaker of the House.
Yep, they found someone
just in time.
If the job stayed
open any longer,
it would have automatically
gone to Ryan Seacrest.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Republicans said Mike Johnson
is their first choice
after the first 10 choices lost.
Then he -- Then him.
Let's just say
if speaker nominees
were "Star Wars" characters,
he's their Jar Jar.
Let's just say if speaker
nominees were Halloween candy,
this guy is a Necco Wafer, okay?
It's like being at a restaurant
and hearing, "Do you have Coke?"
"No." "Pepsi?" "No."
"Sprite?" "No."
"Fine, I guess I'll have
the Mike Johnson."
[ Laughter ]
That's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, the new Speaker
of the House is Mike Johnson.
And if that name
sounds familiar,
it's 'cause it's
on every fake ID.
"Hi. I'm Mike Johnson.
Just two four-packs
of Mike's Hard Lemonade."
I read that Johnson is the most
inexperienced House Speaker
in modern history,
and a lot of people said
that his résumé is lacking.
Then George Santos was like,
"I can help you edit that.
I'm good at -- Just say that
you were president, yeah.
Just say you were
the president for four years.
Who cares?"
Johnson is pretty controversial
because he led the effort
to overturn the 2020
presidential election.
So basically,
whether or not he won today,
he was going to say he did.
Some more big news today.
The judge in former president
Trump's civil fraud trial
fined Trump $10,000
for violating his gag order
a second time
and warned him not to do
it again or it'll be worse.
-Ooh.
-Yep.
Trump could be sentenced
to jail.
Or even worse, a brunch
with Eric and Don Jr.
[ As Trump ]
Send me to the clink.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Meanwhile, during Trump's day
in court yesterday,
one of his lawyers
claimed that at one point
Trump could have bought
multiple NFL teams.
Of course, Trump agrees,
and to show that he's
a big fan of the league,
he even defined
some common NFL terms.
-Oh.
-Yeah, let's see how he did.
First up, for hut, Trump said...
[ As Trump ]
Nobody beats it.
[ Normal voice ]
Next up, for handoff, he said...
Two words.
-Two words.
Up next, for yard lines,
he said...
Wait, what is that?
What are you talking about?
I don't know what he's --
Why would he -- Why would he --
He said it.
I don't know why he said it.
-You're just reading
what he said.
-Next up, for scramble,
he said...
[ As Trump ] I don't like --
I don't want to play Scramble.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Then for
the name Mahomes, he said...
[ Laughter ]
Come on, that's a good --
That's worth it right there.
That's worth
the price of admission.
-Cute.
Shout-out to the gals at work.
That was a cute one.
-That was a good one there,
yeah.
There's more, though.
Next up, for stiff arm,
he said...
Do we have a photo?
Oh, interesting. That's --
[ Laughter ]
-Ohhh!
-Then there's -- for 49ers,
he said...
-What?
-I don't know why -- Why would
he say all these things?
-Why would he say that aloud?
Why would he write it down?
-And finally, for Steelers,
he said...
There you go. That's --
There you go.
He knows the NFL.
He knows football.
Well, switching gears,
in transportation news,
the FAA just got a new leader
after a year and a half
without anyone in charge.
Yeah, I guess for
the last year and a half,
it's been every plane
for themselves.
Yeah, a year and a half.
Yeah.
Apparently he was
in boarding group D, so...
[ Laughter ]
Some business news -- The
long-awaited Tesla Cybertruck
is set to become available
next month.
It's going to weigh
at least 8,000 pounds.
I'm not making that --
Here it is.
You see the photo?
It weighs at least 8,000 pounds.
Yeah, and that's
before the holidays.
Yeah, yeah, it's going to be
a gigantic truck.
And every single one
will have this license plate.
I think that's interesting.
That's --
Why would -- Why would you --
Again, you don't have to.
-Wow.
-They don't have to do that.
[ Applause ]
Well, some TV news.
Today Netflix released
a new documentary series
called "Life on Our Planet
that's narrated
by Morgan Freeman.
Yeah. We love --
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
And it's actually
not the only show
that Morgan Freeman
is narrating right now.
Take a look at this thing I saw.
-Welcome back
to "The Golden Bachelor."
Watch as the septuagenarian male
pursues multiple mates at once.
He pauses for a long time
because he cannot
remember their names.
Finally, he just throws out
a random name as a guess.
-Ellen.
-Whew, that was close.
Now it's off
to the Fantasy Suite,
which is Gerry's mating nest,
and his actions require the
assistance of a small blue pill.
-No, it's interesting.
He does a great job.
Beautiful.
[ Applause ]
Well, this is going viral.
At a Taco Bell in Indiana,
an employee was caught
giving one of their co-workers
a haircut in the kitchen.
The only thing worse
than finding one long hair
in your food is finding
500 short ones, don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
I actually prefer
to spend a few extra bucks
and get my hair cut at Chipotle.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, at a McDonald's
in the U.K.,
one mom said that she found
a cigarette butt
in her son's Happy Meal.
Even worse, the manager said,
"Sorry, I only smoke
when I'm getting a haircut."
[ Laughter ]
A cigarette butt
in a Happy Meal.
Meanwhile, in a Burger King
kid's meal, that's the toy.
[ Laughter ]
Play with it all you want.
Come back, get --
Collect all the
cigarette butts you want.
Finally, have you guys
ever noticed
when you start typing
something on Google,
it automatically tries to
complete the search for you?
Yeah, it autofills
what you're looking for,
but sometimes their suggestions
are a little off, I think.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Google Autofails."
Here we go.
-♪ Google Autofails, yeah ♪
-Look at what I typed in today.
Today I typed in...
And these three things
popped up...
I go, no -- no one wants that.
I don't want to see that.
Here's another one I typed in.
I typed in...
And it said...
I go, that's probably why.
But that's not
what I was typing.
[ Applause ]
After that, I typed in...
It said...
[ Applause ]
Disaster.
Next up, I typed in...
And it autofilled...
[ Laughter, applause ]
♪ Hey, there, Delilah ♪
♪ There is something
I will tell you ♪
After that, I typed in...
And it said...
[ Applause ]
[ As Elvis ] Well, you ain't
seen this side of the story yet.
You ain't seen this side
of me yet, man. Come on.
-Hyah!
-[ Normal voice ]
Next up, I typed in...
And it said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Whee!
-So cute.
-Here's another one.
I typed in...
It said...
[ Applause ]
And you traded him?
-Wow.
-You traded him?
Oh, my God, that's terrible.
And you traded him?
You did?
Oh, I can't believe it.
-Wow.
-And he wouldn't trade you back?
Oh, man.
-Wow.
And he didn't play?
Oh, wow.
-He got injured?
-In the game?
-Oh, man.
Oh, I got to go back
to my files.
[ Laughter ]
-What files do you
have to get to?
-Yeah, just a bunch of files.
-Wait, you're telling me
he's not playing?
He's sick this week?
-Wow.
-Man. That's terrible.
[ Laughs ]
Finally, I typed in...
And it said...
Stick around, everybody.
When we come back,
we're doing something
fun and scary with Cameron Diaz.